[Music]
a three-year-old little boy
is dead after police say his mother
mishandled a gun and shot him and it's a
story that we first brought you here
last night
it happened at an apartment complex in
the northeast valley on arlington street
not too far from charleston and nellis
the i-team's vanessa murphy is live with
the latest developments but she's
learned more about the family vanessa
denise this is described as a terrible
accident but
metro police are saying the mother
should have known better they say
she was showing off a new gun to some
friends with two
children present a bullet a bullet
struck
and killed her three-year-old boy
twenty-four-year-old jasmine vargas
faces
two child abuse charges her bail is set
at 80 thousand dollars
vargas was a no-show in court this
afternoon the judge saying she refused
to be transported there
metro police say she was in a parking
lot with friends and pulled the trigger
of her new gun in the direction of her
son
john jaffe and a friend's child because
she didn't
know it was loaded john was struck in
the head
a neighbor in the apartment complex
drove the mother and child to sunrise
hospital
where he was pronounced dead a metro
lieutenant says vargas
did lawfully purchase that gun recently
and also that he is seeing tragic cases
like this one
too often there is nothing more tragic
than when i show up
and have to talk to people about the
loss or injury
substantial injury to another family
member
that was preventable
lieutenant valenta says three other
people were killed this year in metro's
jurisdiction because a gun was
mishandled
and seven others were injured he also
says out of 11
teen suicides a five were the result of
a gun
not being secured properly the teens
having
access to those firearms he also says
cases like this get referred to the
district attorney's office
the d.a then has to make that decision
on whether to pursue charges
against the gun owner reporting live
vanessa murphy 8 news now